the jurgen experience yeah and i
remember being on the show and then i
remember leaving going she's actually
called bill cosby a douchebag like i
probably should i probably shouldn't do
that
i feel like a lot of people left the
show saying something like that about
time how was the show
that show would not be possible today no
i mean it really was like a podcast in a
lot of ways yeah yeah you know
yeah it really was it was it was a
[ __ ] great show though thank you
it was a great show thanks it really was
and you were the perfect host for it too
because you were loose enough and light
enough with everything that you can kind
of keep the glue together
yeah i mean i took as much abuse as
anybody on that oh yeah but it was
it was a rare moment where like in
perfect name too
tough crowd was a perfect name for it
has there ever been a talk about
bringing that back
oh god yeah everybody talks about it but
i'm like where you know what i mean
what about as a podcast ah people say
that i don't know
why not i mean because
first of all i resented at the time that
i was like
yeah they didn't want you know what i
mean like right who knows what i'm
presenting
i'm fighting against something it's not
even part of the podcast world right and
um but then i was just like
i don't know then i'm gonna you know i
mean getting everybody together
and you know people's careers would fall
left and right
if we did it oh yeah i mean anybody on
there
would they be able to really even speak
honestly today
kinda you gotta have
a career that's pretty locked in already
or you got to be on the on the come up
where you got nothing to lose
it's the guys that are on a television
show that are [ __ ]
yeah like the guys who get a tv show or
you're really worried about losing it
right those guys can't they can't do a
show like that but back then you could
oh back then we did but there it is
colin quinn tough crowd
there it is look at that that is that
patrice patrice
oh my oh he was the star of that [ __ ]
show well norton was great on that show
the apollo was great on that show
everybody was great in that
geraldo there's geraldo and when geraldo
and leary went at it that was one of the
great moments of that show
ten years geraldo's dead two days ago
yeah him and larry that was that was a
good one and lenny clark was there it's
just a great
setup like the way you had it it was
just a great setup patrice literally
it was basically his show as you can see
from that footage
i was a guest he was the host little
chubby jimmy look at jimmy
now in the chubby bunny looks like a fat
fool but um
this was a great [ __ ] show man yeah
but how many episodes did you guys wind
up doing
uh 200 i think wow 220 or something
i have no um can we get you to do it as
a podcast
i don't know because you could get guys
like me guys like
established comics would do it and it
would be wild
you could still do it it could still be
done as a podcast it gets to
because like you have a guy like joey
diaz on he doesn't give a [ __ ]
right you can have those guys and they
will talk freely
yeah and people would love it oh my god
they would love it
yeah it might i don't know i mean over
the years obviously people have brought
it up to me and i was like now because
they could never
do you own the name be free today no but
i got a better one
the original name which everybody took
me off of which is the expression
really more than tough crowd tough room
and i think i can find the name yeah
anyway
either way tough rooms better tough room
as a podcast tough room
why not i don't know
maybe look how many guys in new york
would do it a lot
yes easy yeah norton would do it for
sure 100
well he wouldn't be invited on but
[Laughter]
you brought up the one name of someone
that's not welcome
on the show there's plenty of comics
that we're doing
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love